wollen aber zuerst einmal schauen zu jan
philipp lahms hausen er steht an der
gitschiner straße hier in berlin
kreuzberg einer der orte in der dort
durchsucht worden ist zehn an der zahl
über die ganze stadt verteilt aber
besonders natürlich in berlin-neukölln
gelegen
was haben denn die beamten fälle sucht
oder gehofft zu finden hat man
tatsächlich gehofft dort teile der beute
noch zu finden
ja also ganz klar ist das natürlich
nicht es wurde ja bereits eingangs
erwähnt dass rund 1600 polizeikräfte im
einsatz waren insgesamt 18 objekte
wurden durchsucht und einer der haupt
zukunft punkte er war zumindest hier wo
ich gerade stehe in kreuzberg man sieht
hier ist aktuell überhaupt nicht mehr
los aber heute morgen muss man sich
vorstellen zum beispiel die annastraße
die war komplett abgesperrt und zehn
mannschaftsbusse waren da und die
polizeikräfte waren vermummen serhat
maschinenpistolen sie hatten
schusssichere westen die anwohner hier
war natürlich völlig überrascht und auch
schockiert von diesem einsatz hatten
damit natürlich nicht gerechnet
zum beispiel ich habe mit vielen
anwohnern gesprochen und einer von ihnen
ginge zum beispiel über einen dieser
balkone das sind so durchgänge hindurch
und oder darüber und wollte gerade
bananen und wurde direkt von der polizei
quasi sprichwörtlich überfallen und
durchsucht es ging natürlich aber
hauptsächlich um bashir remo der hier
wohnt im ersten stock hinter mir
die einsatzkräfte sind mit mit
vorschlaghämmern kommen sie sind mit
brecheisen gekommen was natürlich dafür
spricht matthias becker hatte dass er
eben auch schon erwähnt dass das hier
keine zimperlich aktion war dass man
hier gewaltsam auf überrascht hat in
seine wohnung eingedrungen ist und auch
stunden nach diesem einsatz wurden die
wohnungen hier immer noch durchsucht
akribisch bis ins kleinste detail in
jeder ecke schön geworden verrückt weil
man eben gehofft hat in welche
beweisstücke noch zu finden aber oder
auch auf zufallsfunde zu stoßen fest
steht aber das war ja deine frage du
wählen die von juwelenraub dann hat man
hier definitiv nicht gefunden und das
hatte man ja sich so ein bisschen
erhofft in dresden wo für uns fischer
steht mit ihm sprechen wir auch gleich
jan frederik noch eine frage an dich
es gab diese festnahmen hat man dennoch
etwas anderes gefunden was man jetzt
vielleicht auch in anderen fällen also
sozusagen zufallsfunde die man mit denen
man jetzt andere fälle andere verfahren
vielleicht klären kann hat man das
gefunden und zusatz frage wie läuft denn
sozusagen jetzt die
die fahndung nach den zwei noch
flüchtigen zu deiner ersten frage auch
dazu ist es noch nicht ganz klar bzw die
polizei hat sich noch nicht dazu
geäußert was da jetzt genau gefunden
wurde was da jetzt verwertet wurde
es wurden auf jeden fall einige weiß
materialien aus der wohnung heraus
getragen
klassisch natürlich immer elektronische
speichermedien wo sie spuren darauf
finden können und sicherlich wird sich
auch das berliner lka wird es
zufallsfunde gesprochen auch darüber
freuen denn vielleicht gibt es auch
gewisse sachen oder und stücke womit die
auf ein anderes verbrechen hindeuten
bashir am ohr ist ja kommt ja aus dem
klaren belege das heißt er könnte auch
noch weitere verbrechen versteckt sein
entsprechend könnte das natürlich auch
noch weitere hinweise geben aber wie
gesagt die polizeit gesagt dass sie dazu
noch nicht öffentlich bekannt geben wird
hatte jan frederik lang 1000 für uns in
berlin kreuzberg wo eine der
spektakulärsten razzien stattgefunden
hat im clan milieu ganz herzlichen dank
wir gehen nach dresden dort ist
sozusagen ausgangspunkt der
ausgangspunkt für die spur die dann
letztendlich nach berlin ins clan milieu
geführt hat dort steht thomas fischer
thomas du stehst genau an dem gebäude an
dem punkt wo man so ist zu vermuten und
nach jetzigen informationen auch stark
zu vermuten die dna-spur gefunden worden
ist was kannst du uns über diese das
auffinden genaueres sagen ganz richtig
im hintergrund familie die dna-spur
gefunden wurden wir sehen das grüne
gewölbe hinter mir wir sehen den zaun wo
die täter drüber gegangen sind wir sehen
das fenster vielleicht kann man es im
dunkeln erkennen was die täter mit
spreizern auf gekniffen abend das ist
ganz geräuschlos passiert und sie sind
dann reingegangen und haben sehr
professionell gearbeitet es ging alles
ganz schnell
sie hatten vorher noch ein brandanschlag
auf die straßenbeleuchtung verübt auf
einen verteilerkasten das ging überall
das licht aus und sie sind rein und
versucht alle spuren zu vernichten indem
sie dann mit feuerlöschern in die
vitrine reihen gesprüht haben
so professionell wie sie waren sie
töteten ja dann später auch das
fluchtfahrzeug an hatten offensichtlich
magnesium noch rhein gekippt damit das
auto richtig ausbrennt da wird man keine
spuren findet haben sie aber auch spuren
hinterlassen was sie offensichtlich
nicht glaubten tage lang haben die
ermittler am zaun an der wiese und an
der fassade spuren gesichert und da war
ein dna-treffer dabei
nun stellt sich natürlich die frage
werden die juwelen während diese
unschätzbaren kunstschätze wieder
auftauchen oder sind sie tatsächlich
schon ein geschoss machst du da von den
ermittlern in dresden die höhe aus
ermittlerkreisen dass man sich
eigentlich wenig hoffnung macht wenn man
ganz ehrlich ist wenn man jetzt noch was
finden sollte sind es vielleicht
einzelteile
aber ganz ehrlich die ermittler glauben
es ist alles zerlegt es ist das goldes
eingeschmolzen die diamanten sind
geschliffen
man glaubt nicht daran dass man noch was
findet aber wir konnten heute nachmittag
mit der generaldirektorin der dresdner
kunstsammlung sprechen mit marion
ackermann
sie ist die chefin des grünen gewölbes
wir können ja mal reinhören was sie dazu
sagt was können sie uns zum verbleib der
verloren gegangenen preziosen sagen ja
also ich hoffe natürlich dass sich heute
bei der festnahme des dringend
tatverdächtigen und bei den
untersuchungen auch der räume spuren
ergeben
es ist ja anders als bei der goldmünze
aus berlin die eingeschmolzen werden
konnte kann es einfach nicht sein dass
von den juwelen garnituren hier aus dem
historischen grünen gewölbe gar keine
spuren vorhanden sind von daher ist die
hoffnung und die wahrscheinlichkeit
eigentlich jetzt größer denn je dass wir
doch wieder stücke zurückbekommen was
hat ihr haus selbst unternommen um
wieder habhaft zu werden
den verloren gegangenen kunstschätzen
wir haben ja ganz am anfang nach dem
traumatischen erlebnis des einbruchs
sofort einen täter appell gesprochen in
dem wir sehr präzise versucht haben zu
beschreiben dass es eigentlich kaum
möglich ist diese stücke wirklich so
haben wir zu viel geld zu machen da es
sich eben nicht um eine diamanten
handelt wie wir sie heute schätzen
sondern um historische aus indien die
dann auch noch mit einer historischen
schliff garnitur behandelt worden sind
und er außerdem haben wir weltweit in
atlanta riesiges internationales
netzwerk
die abbildungen der stücke eingespeist
und dafür gesorgt dass man überall auf
der welt auch
bescheid weiß und weiß sie aus dem
berühmten historischen grünen gewölbe
stammen von daher eigentlich so als
komplette stücke auch nicht mehr
verkauft werden können
ja aber in dresden schauen jetzt sicher
alle auf diese ermittlung auf diese
razzia heute in berlin
du kannst du dich sicher auch bei den
menschen um hören thomas wie ist die
stimmung wie man die menschen mit dass
dieser fall geklärt wird dieser raub ja
die leute hoffen immer noch sehr dass
die kronjuwelen das ist quasi der
staatsschatz sachsens dass er wieder
auftaucht die sachsen sind sehr stolz
auf dieses museum und auf diese
schmuckstücke auf august den starken der
alles gesammelt hat und sie hoffen
inständig dass irgendwas auftaucht und
sind sehr entsetzt dass
kleinkriminalität dahintersteckt und
offen da das auch eine gerechte strafe
gefunden wird dass die täter nicht nur
mit ein zwei jahren davonkommen
thomas fischer ganz herzlichen dank für
diese schilderungen aus dresden mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren